My husband has four years had periods often on where he continually burps.
Oh, it could start and then go on for several hours. Sometimes he has gaspilled up for hours
after going to bed and then goes on in the night or it could start off in the morning at the stomach
even. Or when he walks or exercises he lifts things any clues. Okay. So yes, my first thought on this
is he probably has a hyalurgy. So I actually have a video on our website how to help yourself with a
hyalurgy. So hyalurgy is so you have a ring of muscle down at the bottom of your esophagus
that constricts. It holds your stomach basically down. So that ring of muscle is in the diaphragm. So
you have a diaphragm that separates your lungs from your abdominal cavity. But you have things
that have to go through that like your esophagus has to go through that and then your stomach sits
below the diaphragm. Well, that ring of muscle what holds the stomach down is called a sphincter.
So a sphincter holds the stomach down and it keeps it there. So problem is you breathe. So your diaphragm
goes down when you that's how you take a deep breath in and therefore your stomach is supposed to
drop down with the diaphragm. So your stomach literally drops down in the abdominal cavity several
inches every time you take a deep breath. If you have adhesions up in your neck from injuries to your
neck let's say you had an auto accident years ago or you just hurt yourself playing football or
some things you have a lot of adhesions in your neck in here that can adhere to your esophagus way up
here. If you have adhesions in your diaphragm, if you have weakness of that sphincter then that sphincter
isn't holding the stomach down and a part of your stomach can literally hurt you up through that sphincter.
That's called a hiatal herdea. Hiatal is hold. It's going to the herdeating through the hole in
the diaphragm. So a hiatal herdea is when your stomach can herdeate up and often that part of the
stomach can just bubble up there. So the top part of the stomach can bubble up in there and you can have
this you know continuous slight hiatal herdea in your stomach and then air gets trapped in there
and you belch a lot and you burp a lot. You can get a lot of pain. It is down there. You can
actually get because it's carried on the same neurological pathways that feed your heart. You can get
what's called a pseudo coronary with a hiatal herdea. So a hiatal herdea can cause a pseudo coronary
event. So personally it feels like they're having a heart attack and it's actually a irritation
of the stomach at the sphincter there. So if you go to our website www.connorsclinic.com and you
search hiatal herdea h-i-a-t-a-l herdea you'll see I have a blog post actually I have a video with
I'm teaching my staff and teaching one of my staff how to pull down that stomach. If you have a
hiatal herdea where it's completely herdeated and it's a medical condition it's getting much
you know more serious we have to have surgery. But 99 times out of 100 it is more intermittent
hiatal herdea so it can bubble up there. Most of the time it's tied to also a decrease in
hydrochloric acid production in the stomach. So I do have a blog post on hydrochloric acid issues. So
look up HCl or hypochloridria. Look up my blog post on that as well. 9 times out of 10
hiatal herdea is tied to that. Hiatal herdeas are extremely common in little babies. That's why
little teeny infants can have projectile vomiting because that sphincter isn't perfectly formed. So the
baby's drinking mylas melp and it just goes right up into that bubble. The bubble's called the
mageblons and the stomach and it could literally just when the diaphragm constricts it just shoots
right out and the person can have projectile vomiting. The little baby does. Doing that doesn't happen
in adults but they get a lot of pain down there. They get a lot of belching. They feel like there's
something right at the bottom of their sternum and it is an air bubble. At the bottom of the sternum
that's pushing up into the diaphragm and it can become it can be very irritating. So hiatal herdea
functional hypochloridria what you're dealing with and it's something that it just doesn't go away
by itself. You have to continue to work out and continue to pull it down. If you go to a car
factor that does kinesiology they know how to fix that as well. It's not just a one-time thing you
really got to do it yourself on a regular basis as well.